xuống đột bú trang tại bình dưới Thai Lan Kang Kho Chià, ngày 20 năm tháng bài,
tiếp độc dính biến phức tạm, khi giáo chanh Lan giọng sang nhiều cu vực mới,
với cần độc phó kích xa tạng đáng kẻ.
Nhất mê hai đẹp nông là người dịch giọc đường biên, trong đó có nhiều khu dịch cư bị phó bán chú,
bột hàng chăm nhìn người ở cả hai phía vài sơ tán khẩn cấp.
Yt nhất mời sáng người, phần lớn là dừng thường thái Lan.
Thủ thướng tâm quyến thái Lan phùm tham vách trời này,
hãy hai mình làm tháng bài, cạnh báo rằng các cục đục độ xin bên dưới,
giữa nước mề với cấp phù chia, hóng thì cơ leo thăng thành chuyến tranh.
Chưa đó, ngày hai mình tư tháng bài, ông nhận định tình hình khi đó chỉ là một cục đục độ.
Nặp biệt là phía sau chanh Lan này của giấu hiệu là tháng nghiêm trọng hơn,
với dự tham ra của phó bình hẳn ngặp và tên lợi chiến thuật.
Hãy làm đã chịn hai các nơi bị cứu trở và quân ý đến các tình sát bên dưới,
và thấy làm xưa tất cả một chăm ba mình ngàn dân,
năm hẹn cho khi cấp phù chia đống cửa trình học và hình chưa dự dời dân thường,
ra khỏi các lần làm trong tầm bản tên lợi.
Đây sẽ có xung đột Mỹ Trung Quốc và chú tịch ASEAN để sát và cho chung dân,
bình yên thấy lăn khẳng định chỉ tất nhiệm đàn phán chực tiếp các phù chia,
cỏi đây là xung đột dựa hai cú ra.
Nấp dưới này, phản ảnh mong muốn kiểm soát tình hình mà không để cú tế hóa không hoàn.
Nhưng trong bối cảnh đục độ lăng dựng,
và các tình đối thoại chưa được hết lập hiệu quả.
Mười cứ xung đột kéo dài và vật khỏi tầm kiểm soát bấm đàng hiện hư.